muito boa tarde é todas e todos espero
que a vida impõe é
é um imenso prazer estar aqui hoje
agradeço a ana leal fredrico o convite
embora é pra ser sincero não sei se irei
fazer porque é fácil convidar alguém
para vir falar as coisas são mais
complicadas quando nos apercebemos que o
mote entre nós e as palavras eu confesso
que sou uma pessoa muito limitada para
não tenha grandes experiências de vida
para você contar e por isso eu vou
tentar falar do pouco que acho que saí
porque essa eficiência e portanto eu vou
tentar colocar a ciência entre nós e as
palavras o objetivo da minha deste
monólogo infelizmente ao mall é mostrar
a importância que as perguntas têm em
ciência mas as respostas às perguntas e
por isso ao longo destes 18 minutos fará
duas perguntas e meia em que se calhar a
média é mais importante de todos como
diz falar de ciência e da minha área de
competência que tem um nome composto da
inteligência artificial
estou com um pouco de imaginação para
fazer avançar este é mais um avançado
que não só tem 18 minutos é melhor
continuar vou falar sobre inteligência
artificial mas não vou dar flexões
rigorosos não vou preocupar com isso há
muitos clichês sobre o que é a
inteligência artificial e eu estava
aliás de desfazer um que além do chefe é
um equívoco a pouco penso que o pedro
basílio
na sua intervenção diz ao que eu fiz aí
nós somos máquinas perfeitas
penso que foi a expressão que utilizou e
eu acho que é o contrário nós humanos
infelizmente não somos máquinas
perfeitas o que é inteligência
artificial procura é criar máquinas
perfeitas desumanizando mas é isso que
nós procuramos fazer preço em vez das
eleições
vamos mostrar se conseguisse mais uma
o próximo estado
o que não exige como v
sabem que há uma diferença fundamental
em tempo gente artificial e humana é que
a humana não é capaz de perceber que
estava ligará esta parede pra começar a
fazer as projeções e eu é minha defesa
vê que partir do princípio que o
prefeito estaria pronto a funcionar e é
assim que nós no nosso dia-a-dia
funcionamos é assim que eu gostava que
acontecesse
então muito rapidamente o tempo voa é
dizer que a imprensa oficial está hoje
por exemplo nós de áreas verdes maneiras
tanto pode ser quando fazemos uma
consulta da google quanto entramos no
site da amazônia e nos dão recomendações
porque é que nós devemos ler ou o que
vemos comprar e em um monte de
aplicações da nossa vida como podíamos
nos smartphones e conversamos dialogamos
e linguagem natural
ganhamos nossa câmera fotográfica e
somos capazes de fazer face recognition
ocr reconhecimento de caracteres forma
automática
usamos gols de limpeza que são pequenos
ao tomate somos capazes de reprogramar o
nosso gps para dizer qual é a minha
maneira de ver o quanto a para o ponto e
julgar nos fazemos imensos jogos e em
todas essas espécies da nossa vida como
nós usamos nós usamos técnicas de
inteligência artificial e é isso que é
importante estarmos unidos cria falar
sobre perguntas que a primeira pergunta
é saber se podem ou não podem as
máquinas ser inteligente
é não é uma pergunta fácil o transponder
desloco que o conceito inteligência é
algo que ainda hoje está por clarificar
por isso eu vou
em vez de dizer o que a insurgência vou
criar uma espécie de versão antecipando
a minha resposta operacional é esse
grande problema
vou falar um pouco
muito rapidamente da ciência e da sua
história da ciência moderna mas também
confesso que rodará uma visão européia
do que foi a ciência ao longo do tempo e
confesso que será extremamente injusto
para com outras culturas que foram
capazes de produzir ciência que nós hoje
os anos sobretudo as culturas orientais
e quando nós olhamos pra história da
ciência moderna com muitos dados em 1243
konko perna há pelo menos três aspectos
que gostaria de realçar a ciência
constituiu se em torno da matéria fez as
primeiras reflexões que fizemos também
sobre a vida e sobre o momento esses
três aspectos são os três grandes
domínios científicos que hoje ainda
existem e temos imensos avanços no
conhecimento científico é muito severa é
esta expressão chover em torno do objeto
de matéria em torno do objeto vida ou em
torno do objeto mas que eu trouxe este
aspecto da nossa história para realçar
três momentos fundamentais em que eu
digo
a procura é psicológico são momentos em
que nós humanos fomos confrontados com
as nossas limitações e começamos a ver é
um pouco no livro espuma dos dias de
glória jean
começamos a ver a nossa casa em colher
em colher em colher a nossa supremacia
cada vez mais que você posta em causa
desde logo com o copérnico que nos diz
que até não é o centro do universo nós
evitamos mais um universo mais uma um
planeta terra numa galáxia qualquer
eventualmente de entrada porque até o
próprio com 700 é muito emotivo mais
tarde juntaram em torno da vida vai
dizer nós não temos nenhuma resistência
especial nós e qualquer outro animal
temos a mesma origem e finalmente já
mais tarde fraudes ou vazamento vem
dizer que nossa pertença racionalizado
fica em sanitários porque o que há é uma
desconstrução deus existem vários erros
e que no momento nós podemos ser um
dentro vários eu trouxe aqui porque eu
creio que a dificuldade que nós temos
como humanos em aceitar partilhar a
inteligência com as máquinas é porque já
não temos já não somos o centro do
universo
já não temos uma existência uma criação
especial
já somos sem as brechas na limitada ou
menos deixem de inteligência não nem
carro de casa não junto às paredes dessa
casa e é essa uma dificuldade que nós
temos que saber ultrapassar e por isso
aqui o que eu li não digo eu dizer muita
gente já sabe se ela aparece como uma
quarta de continuidade em um momento em
que nós vamos ter que sentar para
criarmos com as máquinas a insurgência
aquela imagem imagem muito conhecida
quando um programa de computador de
plugins envolver na ibm derrotou o
campeão mundial da prova
e de alguma maneira isso mostra que as
máquinas são capazes de derrotar os
humanos humanos sofisticado em atividade
que seja em pensamento abstrato o
raciocínio também é o sofisticado
agora está tudo muito bonito mas não ao
longo do tempo foram aparecendo idéias
para mostrar que isso é possível
logo nos anos 50 do século passado
altura em que propôs um texto que o
teste era assim imaginem dois
compartimentos completamente isolados a
não ser através de um processo
comunicacional escrito mas nada num dos
compartimentos está um humano que esse o
papel do provedor no outro compartimento
eu publico 1º um homem e uma mulher que
tem o papel de não deixar que o
entregador descubra quem é o homem de
quem me a turim entrou jogou o seguinte
nós ao longo de várias interações
estatisticamente não for possível o
entregador distingue quem é o homem ea
mulher
então nós temos que dizer que se é
resultado da inteligência do homem e da
mulher que tentam esconder quem são o
seu génio do posto em que surgem então
agora vamos fazer uma modificação na
sala onde estão os dois humanos
vamos retirar um dos humanos ao fracasso
escolheu a mulher eu não tinha essa
imagem e semelhança de compartilhar
catarina martins mas não o contrário
mantém a mulher assim aqui eu mantenho
minha mulher ia ter o homem reduzir a
sua insignificância para o teste turim e
coloco lá um computador e agora turim
desde se no mesmo processo for
impossível entre jogadores distingue
quem é o homem da casa mulher ea máquina
então os dois duas entidades que estão
do outro lado também elas provaram tem
essa capacidade essa inteligência
esse foi o teste fiel proposto e que
hoje é de origem monte de programas que
estatisticamente passaram o texto tem
grande dificuldade em manter o último
novos e por isso eu trago aqui um texto
porém para fazermos em um tamanho da
minha varia de testes turim
vou mostrar as duas imagens uma delas
foi feita por um pintor muito conhecido
mundialmente famoso e outra foi feita
por um computador e portanto vamos
tentar perceber quem fez o quê quem é o
autor de cada uma das obras que estão as
duas imagens para as pessoas que têm sua
cultura artista que temos aqui vários já
ouvimos hoje seguramente ele consegue
identificar facilmente então para quem
quem não sabe a resposta
eu pergunto quem sente incapaz de fazer
a distinção é só isso quer ser levanta o
braço
não está mal mas tá bom tá bom é isso
significa que é a grande maioria não é
capaz de fazer a distinção significa que
uma obra feita por um manobra feita por
um artista coloca nesse caso é não não
consegue ser ser é não consigo fazer
essa descrença não consigo fazer essa
despesa é bom mas isso era apenas para
mais ou menos a mesma conversa a gente
conseguir introduzir aqui alguma
ginástica que quanto mais não seja
notório praça fica assim mais - costa é
agora operacionalizar isto é
operacionalizar isto e vou mostrar como
é que isto maioritariamente foi feito
isto é comércio com seus programas que
são oficialmente imprudente e vou depois
transportar isso para a minha a minha
segunda pergunta se o tempo se o tempo
deixar a primeira dentro sabe se a web
design e design é inteligência desenhada
desenhada por humanos
eu olho para os homens e para as
mulheres os manos vejo como é que os
seus jovem problemas é porque ele
encontra um conjunto de princípios
relativamente simples resolução e medos
e os princípios dentro de um computador
foi feito por exemplo venceu o gaspar ó
é essa é a resposta maioritária da
inteligência artificial aquilo que
alguns chamam de comportamento
imprudente artificial simbólica
agora esta maneira de resolver o
problema de colocar em vigência das
máquinas está em viajava está enviesada
e é possível encontrar outras formas de
fazê-lo é e pra isso eu tomo aí vai
começar pouco do que as três grandes
áreas científicas conseguir em torno da
matéria da vida e da mente
foram vistas isoladamente na base das
idéias de kato uma vida muito cartesiana
dividir as coisas e hoje cada vez mais
nós sabemos que isso não pode ser assim
que há uma interligação muito grande há
uma transversalidade entre as diferentes
áreas e outros 800 objetos do
conhecimento das diferentes áreas sentir
porque na verdade o que nós temos é uma
grande área chamada matéria porto da
matéria
num determinado momento do processo
evolutivo apareceu a vida é vivida
emergiu da matéria e finalmente da vida
emergiram os agentes cognitivos são
capacidades mentais sociais para iphone
e por isso é nova visão artificial e
alguns mais recentemente estão a tentar
impor uma visão em que nós tentamos
limitar a visa
nós queremos responder à pergunta não
das máquinas poderiam não poderem ser
inteligentes mas eu quero responder à
pergunta de saber se eu posso fazer
evoluir uma máquina como se a máquina
fosse desde logo um instrumento físico
se tornar se numa entidade ecológica e
mais tarde motivado cognitiva é esse
processo é olhar para a realidade como
se fossem meteórica aquela boneca russa
estão todas umas dentro das outras todas
dentro de uma das outras e como devem
calcular a resposta é sim
vão ver um vídeo mas primeiras
tentativas nos inícios dos anos 90
em que um cientista carlos simples se
preocupou com fazer evoluir a morfologia
os corpos apenas copos de café lá o
corpo momento nós começamos também
coisas muito simples
qual é a idéia é preciso porque nos
paraolímpicos são chamados blocos
construtores e fazer com que as lojas
constatou se possam juntar entre si e
são julgados com a sua capacidade de ter
um comportamento adequado ao meio onde
estão aqui é um meio a quatro agora 16
treino sua qualidade de vida porque
sabem nadar 1 e 4 se consegue movimentar
se no maio numa e trânsito e como nós
fazemos isto é pegamos no conjunto de
soluções arbitrárias e essas funções
como a natureza vão evoluir por
processos que nós chamamos mutações como
os seus vídeos e por cruzamentos o
crossover combinações entre diferentes
entre este processo e no final vamos
encontrar aqui como vêm de diferentes
morfologia senão vou mostrar o processo
eo piloto então vamos para o fim da
redução de frente formas de diversidade
como acontece também na natureza e agora
o passo seguinte
estamos a aguardar uns anos esta quarta
é não apenas fazer alguma fugir mas
também entidades que passo de resolver
problemas com a internet com capacidades
cognitivas e vamos dar alguns um alguns
alguns exemplos do que nós andamos a
fazer nós somos capazes
projetar a antenas de comunicação
privada desempenho usando essas
metodologias somos capazes de resolver
um problema que parece por 90 km e é
contido problema do caixeiro viajante
alguém tem que visitar uma cidade um
conjunto cidade uma só vez reforçar a
sua origem está no preço o tempo o tempo
mínimo
somos capazes de otimizar o processo de
tratamento entre radioterapia
identificando um número que faz estrada
precisamos usar e os anos a incidência
dessas festas
somos capazes de estudaram o pulsar uma
cidade aqui lisboa entendendo a cidade
como organismo vivo e ver os processos
de engarrafamento segunda circular é
tudo isso nós fazemos com princípios
muito simples uma porção de soluções
candidatas
julgamos essa população com mudanças em
cada indivíduo e cruzamentos internet
olhamos para a qualidade escolhemos os
melhores eram pequenos e com isso
tranqüilo também nós somos capazes de
criar soluções inteligentes foi a
problemas de elevada complexidade ea
única coisa que nós fizemos foi mudar a
pergunta chegar a inteligência não a
partir de cognição humana chegar a
inteligência para que o andar baixo a
partir da vida dos mecanismos da vida
eventualmente um dia pensaremos em
frente e não desistiremos
o nível até a matéria porque é uma
ilusão pensar se que é única
possibilidade de vida é aquela que é
baseada no carbono
nós andamos a procurar mostrar a tentar
mostrar que eles podem também servir
depois inteligência a partir do silício
que é a matéria prima que são feitos são
feitos computadores bom e com isso estar
à conversa que eu tinha para para vos
dizer meus olhos com um prazer enorme
com as três minutos que lhe restam e
saber que o expositor turar durante mais
alguns surdos da minha imensa e mensal
alegria mas claro que eu sei que foi
também nós sabemos nós todas e todos
sabemos todas e todos sabemos que quando
nós no momento chegamos a um leque é um
conhecimento um fim
não estamos mais do que alcançar ea
pensar novo naquilo que vem eu vou
mostrar um vídeo que fala da maia
pergunta que eu acho que é mais
importante todas vamos ver
sim
o corpo do bebê
até aqui chips atom falha o show online
ayotte extinguisse letalidade era ok
volta
o nome da vila rosa
um carro
taiko que
ae
andar
o irã eu penso que todos fizeram é o
tempo programado a morte do republican
frank humano e o próprio e acabado com a
vida o que acaba formando frança
frank é este filme eu creio que a grande
questão que se coloca a todas e todos
se calhar é pergunta maior do tempo e
hoje todos os tempos é é sabendo o que é
consciência nas várias continuidade
sobre a matéria sobre a vida e sobre
cognição e no campo da inteligência que
é o nosso refúgio falei da quarta de
continuidade em 200 artificial que nos
meteu na aparência
na aparência para a nossa maior
limitação eu creio que ela nos deixa é
precisamente o que extinguiria que é
sermos humanos conscientes em manaus
temos máquinas sim mas em perfeita sobre
ela